hi my name is Rebecca Kim I'm a Southern
Baptist Aplin at Harvard since 1998 but
I came to Harvard in 1991 so I began to
teach the Bible to the students here and
I formed a BSK the student organization
which stands for ancient Baptist Student
Colonia Base Korea
I grew up with the education or
teachings of Confucius Chinese is color
few thousand years ago yeah so I was the
first Christian in my family I have nine
siblings
including me my parents I have 10
children so I was the most promising
child of ten and all of a sudden I
betrayed my family Confucius of family
and I was almost a disowned by my family
so I was so frustrated because of my
true love in God couldn't be
communicated with the rest of my family
including my parents so I began to pray
for them the miracle happened and most
of my family became Christians and many
of my siblings became ministers like me
and a deathbed my father became a
Christian when just before he passed
away in Los Angeles more than 30 years
ago
I loved to teach the Bible to everyone
whoever is interested in learning the
words of God please come to me I'm
willing to teach all of you either on
one on one level or a small group or
large group god bless you